here's something else you don't want to
miss on hoodie is taking a seat on hot
bench dismisses complaint give her stuff
back great now let's go I thought it was
fun and how many times could you have
different kinds of fun at my age yeah I
love that she's here making it more fun
for Judy on Monday husband Jerry a
retired judge himself also sits in on a
case he still looks great too sharp as
ever so he won't need any judging tips
from Judy but back in the day she was
giving him interviewing tips explain
something to you you have to incorporate
the question she's in your answer if you
don't do that you're gonna wind up on
the editing floor we try again we were
visiting the Sheindlin family in Putnam
Valley New York back in 1997 Jerry and
Judy were like a comedy duo I do what I
do everything make fun of me no I do
everything you breathe in and out I do
everything I clean inhale do I do that
well regularly I can rely on that like
clockwork at the time Judge Judy had
only been on for a year maybe next year
if the program was successful we'll get
it both with a motor well it was
successful all right these are the girls
15 years later we visited their newly
remodeled mansion in Greenwich
Connecticut this is the dining room
no this is the kitchen this is the
kitchen part of Judy's TV empire is hot
bench where she chosen a new judge for
the panel starting Tuesday it'll be
former New York jurors Michael Cory
arrow we started out as young lawyers
together on one case Judy was trying to
convict two of Michael's defendants and
they were actually innocent and the star
witness that I was feeding hamburgers
and fries - in a hotel turned out to be
the actual shooter
you